The wilderness is an unforgiving place.
There are so many different
ways to die out there.
We've covered a lot of survival
tactics and situations.
Like, a lot, a lot.
But unless you know you're
gonna be attacked by a bear,
you might have missed that one video
about what to do when
you're attacked by a bear.
That's why this video may save your life.
OK, you're stranded in the wilderness.
Congratulations!
What do you do first?
Whether in the woods, in the mountains,
or on a deserted island,
here are a few essential steps
survivalists say to follow.
First, signal for rescue.
The sooner you return to
civilization, the better.
Your best chance of
escape is to be rescued,
so use your resources to signal any ships
or planes that might pass by.
But if rescue doesn't come,
the next step is to avoid injury.
Your feet are some of your most important
and vulnerable tools for survival.
Boots will protect you
from cutting your feet
as you explore the area for
the next step to survival.
Find fresh water.
While a human can survive
for 40 days without food,
we can't live more than eight
to 10 days without water.
If you have to choose between dehydration
and unfiltered water,
take your chances with the water.
But if you can, fresh water
is gonna be your best bet.
Sources of fresh water
include caves, rain,
and making your own from salt water.
If you're by the ocean, you can
convert salt water to fresh.
Fill a can with salt water
and then put a second
container over the can.
This will collect the fresh water
that evaporates out of the can.
You need at least 1 liter
of water per day to survive.
Look for signs of life if you
can't find a water source.
Vegetation, birds, and insects
can all mean nearby water sources.
Roots, vegetables, and
cacti can all contain water,
and mashing them with a rock
will release some liquid.
Water flows downhill, so be sure to check
low-terrain canyons and mountain bases
that could be home to a water source.
Morning dew can be collected with a cloth
and then wrung out into your mouth.
But just make sure you
collect it before sunrise
or it could evaporate
before you get to it.
If you're lucky enough
to catch a rainfall,
use cups or any possible
containers to catch it.
If possible, build a water-catching tarp.
This will allow even more
water to be collected.
So hopefully this never happens to you,
but let's say you found yourself
in an extreme situation:
You're out of food, you're out of water,
and the only liquid nearby is your own.
The Army has a field manual,
which has a do-not-drink list
for just such an occasion.
That list includes fish juices, blood,
alcohol, seawater and, yes, urine.
Drinking urine is basically
like drinking seawater.
It's gonna dehydrate you,
which is the exact
opposite of what you want.
To make matters worse,
if you keep drinking it,
the severe dehydration can trigger
abnormally low blood pressure.
Low blood pressure means less
blood flow to vital organs
like your heart, lungs, and kidney,
which can be damaged or fail as a result.
That is not good.
Adding to your trouble is urea.
Urea is basically waste.
It's not supposed to be in your body.
That's why your kidneys
filter it out of your blood
and into your urine,
which ordinarily then
just leaves your body.
But if you then drink the urine,
your kidneys have to work twice as hard
to filter out that extra urea,
and that could lead to kidney failure.
Seems like drinking urine
might be your kidneys' worst nightmare.
Just stick with fresh
water if you can get it.
You should also know how to build a fire.
You need a dry patch of
ground about 4 feet wide.
Build a ring of rocks or
dig down a few inches.
This will keep the fire insulated.
Then use paper, dry grass,
or pine needles as tinder.
Pile loosely in the center
and top with kindling.
If that kindling's wet, you're
gonna need a lot more tinder.
If you're lucky enough to
have a lighter or matches,
ignite the tinder and
gently blow on the fire.
If you don't have a lighter or matches,
you need to use friction
to create an ember.
You can also create sparks
with a flint and steel.
If you need to, you
could always use a lens
to harness the sun's light.
As the kindling catches,
gradually add more.
Once you have a nice, healthy flame going,
begin to add the firewood.
Arrange the pieces in a tepee shape.
This fire will burn hot and quickly,
so be sure to keep it fed.
As you explore the area,
you might be trying to find
your way back to civilization.
You may remember hearing
how moss only grows
on the north side of trees.
Great, right?
Unfortunately, that's a myth.
Moss grows wherever
conditions are moist and cool.
This is often the north side of trees
since they are less likely
to receive direct sunlight,
but in the woods, trees can
be shaded from any direction,
so it's not safe to go by this rule.
There are some unseen dangers
that could definitely slow you down.
You should also know
how to deal with these.
Chances are you won't
encounter quicksand that often,
but just in case you do,
here's how to escape quicksand.
First of all, don't panic.
It's impossible to drown in quicksand
because humans actually float in it.
What makes it so dangerous
is its viscosity.
Once disturbed, quicksand
becomes much more viscous,
trapping whatever it envelops.
Don't ask your friend to pull you out;
they'll only be able to
dislodge your top half,
and that's no good.
Here's how you get out of it.
Wiggle your legs to create a pocket
for water to trickle down.
This will loosen the
sand around your legs.
Feel free to lose your
shoes if you have to.
Next, lay back.
The more you distribute your
weight across the surface,
the harder it will be to sink.
Now work on your backstroke.
Use your arms to propel
yourself backwards.
The quicksand will
actually keep you afloat,
and you'll be able to pull your legs free.
Once you reach solid ground,
roll away from the quicksand,
and then you'll be clear
of that sticky situation.
Mother Nature isn't the
only danger out here.
Wildlife is also a threat
if you don't know how
to react appropriately.
Like snakes.
Most snakes will avoid you,
but if you happen to get
bitten by venomous snakes,
you can always suck the venom out, right?
Nope, that is another myth.
A venomous bite delivers the venom
straight to your bloodstream.
In fact, trying to suck it out
could transfer the venom to your mouth.
It could also further infect the wound.
Instead, hold the bitten limb
below or close to heart level.
This may prevent the venom
from reaching your heart.
If you're in some parts of the world,
you have a good chance of
running across some bears.
Coyote Peterson: Do not take
out your phone and think,
"Ooh, there's a bear, I'm
gonna get a photograph of it."
You see a bear, that bear hasn't seen you,
the best thing to do is
slowly backstep yourself
out of the situation.
If you do encounter a bear
and that bear does see you,
more times than not, the bear
is actually more afraid of you
than you should be of it,
and it will take off on its own.
If you are attacked, do
not try to outrun a bear.
I know a lot of people out there who say,
"I could outrun a bear."
You can't outrun a bear.
However if it makes a threat towards you,
make yourself look big.
Scream, act crazy, do whatever you can.
Tim MacWelch: In the event
of an attack by a black bear,
the most important thing you
can do is fight for your life.
A grizzly bear, however, is much larger,
much more powerful, and
way out of our league
for a hand-to-hand fight.
With a grizzly bear, your
best chance of survival
is to curl up in a ball, play
dead, and cry for your mama.
Peterson: Protect your head
and your neck and just hold on,
because it's probably gonna
be a very painful ride.
But oftentimes, that bear will
end up leaving and going on.
Give yourself a few minutes,
endure through the pain,
and once you know that the animal
has moved off into the underbrush,
that's when you quietly get yourself up
and you go seek medical
attention as quick as possible.
Narrator: Probably the
most important lesson
to survive in an unfamiliar area
is to become familiar with it.
Study the terrain,
environment, and wildlife
of any new area before you enter it.
Let people know where you will be
and how long you'll be out there.
And bring the necessary gear for that trip
and every emergency situation
that you can think of.
Using these tips,
hopefully you'll never need
to drink your own pee in the first place.